making sure that the stream is active it
does look like it's
ready oh it's saying go live let's see
if this is sorry
between the video a little bit
yeah you can ignore the video um and
just
uh concentrate on the interview channel
let's see if this works now okay
this should be going live very soon
i've got a notification on my ipad that
we are live
and uh it's just a matter of you know
are we actually live can you trust
what these big tech corporations are
doing to us
let's see here yes i see us all right
james jordan welcome back
again to the into the impossible podcast
we are now live
you're joining us from santa monica
you've been a friend of the show and a
friend uh
to me and uh thank you so much for
joining us we're here to talk about your
book
the speed of life but not that much
because the thing i always hate is when
i would be interviewed
by a podcaster who didn't read the book
and didn't care about the book but but
wanted to save his
listeners the expense and time of
reading the book so they would say to me
tell us what's in your book tell us what
the reader will learn
and what your conclusion is etcetera
etcetera i don't want to talk about that
but i do want to say that this book has
a subtitle an
illustrated novel which is uh which is
quite lovely i actually bought the
kindle
book i have the hard copies courtesy of
you but i want to look at some of the
illustrations in the book
after we do the following thing which is
something
that authors are told and readers are
told never to do
which is to judge a book by its cover i
want to ask you
how did you come up with the cover
illustration and the title of this book
ryan is it possible for you to stop your
ipad
sorry you're you're coming through a
little bit choppy i
i you wanna that's better i was asking
if you could turn it
down on your ipad because there's a
delay in the
of the sound okay i'll turn off that
here it should be fine do you hear me
okay
yeah that's perfect this car this
yeah go for it i can hear you all right
this cover took a long time to develop
um the there's a character named andrew
who is
a very young shaman uh a seminal
uh of mixed race and in
this picture he's paddling his canoe up
there la
river towards
uh toward what i hoped would be a
supernova
um a connection between the con
and the earth um
i had an original uh illustrator
who did anyway not not as good a
cover as this one eric savage my current
illustrator this is his second
cover but every illustration on the
cover
um is inspired by a scene in the
and this particular scene in section
seven
and uh andrew has been
at jupiter and is able to see the past
through a uh reflection from the sun of
event
earth that come back through a worm
and he wants to get back to earth to
warn people who will be in danger
and so it is sort of a mind-bending
story that goes
uh to the depths of outer space into the
heart of the everglades to
the criminal justice system to
interracial relations
to uh some very startling uh kind of
gripping
um almost almost like a uh a film
it's it's very theatrical and this is
your first book right i mean this is
your first book of fiction or
non-fiction right
this is my first my first novel
and when you set out to write it did you
did you have the story complete or
did it develop as you went along
i uh an image
of a rape
and uh the mother is accused
of sending the rapist to harmony
most of the
sorry do you hear me james can you hear
me
hello hello james you hear me okay
hello
james you're frozen there
can everybody hear me out there
i have an excellent connection it says
but james is not appearing
um hopefully james will be back on let
me text him and see if he is available
to come back into the stream i hear you
guys hear me
james is coming in and out it says um
let's see here
um
yeah i'm getting good signal but uh
something's wrong with his signal
anyway we're still uh we're still going
over the speed of light which is james's
novel here and it's an illustrated novel
uh and it's a rather unique work of
uh literature in that it blends physics
and
astronomy with uh a murder mystery
uh which is uh quite quite surprising
and and some
and some difficult concepts to get into
which i said i don't
really want to talk too much about uh
because i don't like to give it away and
some of it quite frankly is
not suitable for young viewers and young
listeners
and i'm hoping james will come back on
let's see here
if i can get the window up here and see
if he'll
join us back again yeah he is frozen
still
this happens not all together
infrequently well with the streaming
software that i have here
but um hopefully it won't be a permanent
delay although i know he is being very
generous with his time
and uh with the resources that he's
dedicated to this podcast
um so he's actually a good friend i'll
take the time just to read
some of the um encomia some of the
compliments on this book are really uh
you know they come from the highest
heights of uh
of academia from kip thorne to tc boyle
who's a a well-known uh
eminent author and let's see
i don't see his he is not on
i should have a backup set up for such
events
uh but we are still live so i'm going to
keep going i'm going to read to you
some of the acknowledgements first of
all which i always like to read i like
to read the cover and i like to read the
acknowledgements
i like to read the end of a book because
you never know if you're going to make
it
all the way through some events going to
come up like uh happened to kip thorne
uh who won the nobel prize during the
writing of this book so kip thorne was
was james's science advisor
he read the passages related to
astrophysics on several occasions
as he revised and rewrote he wrote he
read the entire manuscript when he
thought it was complete
provided him with extensive notes and
insightful advice
it's pretty amazing and also tc boyle
read chapters as his writing progress
provided him
with invaluable editorial and structural
suggestions he read the manuscript in
its entirety
it was complete and he is of course a
distinguished professor of english
emeritus
at the university of southern california
not the university of california where i
am but
that great school to the north uh in los
angeles
and then uh the late victor wolfenstein
who's a professor of political science
and political theory again these are
really amazing
uh amazing contributors to this book and
i think you know his wide-ranging
intellect really shines through here
um still hoping he'll come back on
before it's too late uh i know that i am
coming through i believe
james is in deep thought yes that's
right
so you guys i assume can still hear me
there's about
22 people watching right now and uh
the only one missing is as our guest of
honor i hope he'll come back on soon
um so i want to uh talk a little bit
about some of the big themes in the book
with james and hopefully he'll be back
on and they involve
uh astrophysics determinism time
travel uh and uh and really far out
things like wormholes like his friend
uh professor kip thorne who read the
book and
had much to say about it as well in the
science advisory role it's not too often
you get a nobel prize winner to be your
science advisor on a novel
which is your first book so i'm very
interested to know how that connection
was made
so i'm really hoping that he'll come
back in let's see here i'm going to take
that guy
out all right so now it's just me you
should all just see me seeing me
now i'm hoping that he will realize that
he has to check his darn email
um yeah i'm getting uh
okay please log in again okay all right
now he's gonna be back hopefully
bear with us
and when he comes on there will be a
tinkling sound you will hear it
and hopefully that will be sufficient
there it is i hear a tinkling sound
james are you back at my back do you see
me
i see you you're back now you're live
okay
all right sorry but i'm glad to be back
and i thank you for everything you said
all your kind words i didn't see the
email i was just about to log in
all right great all right so we are back
live
and we are talking about some of the big
themes in the book
uh but first i can't help but but wonder
how did you get connected to kip
thorne and leonard milad now
well um i knew leonard kept
him at parties at chip's house
very state of the
philosophy
and talk to leonard about it and was
about to give my pitches
to why i couldn't possibly do it he said
oh i know i know there's ethic
and but even on it so what could i
so uh
i i've known kipp for a long time that
uh carol is watching this
are the defensive stars
that's great and uh you've been in los
angeles for a long time and you also
knew
tc uh boyle right that that's the other
uh in comium on the back uh from the
courtroom to the swamp primeval
to the underpinnings of the universe
james jordan takes us on a wild ride
a hugely ambitious and thoroughly
enjoyable triumph of a first novel all i
can say is bravo
and of course uh he is a renowned author
and his owner how did you get to know uh
professor boyle
i i
i went to grad school in korea
and so i think it's great
and now uh-huh
so
so uh you were talking earlier can you
hear me okay james you're you're
still coming in a little choppy i don't
are you on an ethernet connection or a
wi-fi connection
internet connection and i have an
external microphone
it's very strange everyone on the stream
is saying i'm sounding okay but
but the uh but the audio is coming in
and out yeah maybe the microphone a
little closer
and uh shut off any and shut off any
streams if you have any
videos running please shut them off um
because that will
uh affect your bandwidth um so i want to
talk about some of the
as i said some of the illustrations in
this book it's an illustrated novel
and and you've kindly put me in touch
with eric who did some of the art for
the
for the uh for this video um of the
artwork that's in here
some of it is cultural i would say some
of it is
astrophysical how did you determine kind
of the
the the balance between how technical
this was going to get it's not a physics
book and your audience is
fiction readers it's not non-fiction
science readers
how did you find the balance between the
hero's journey of the story i really see
it as
a journey and maybe it'll continue in
future books
but um how do you strike the balance
between the technical and the
sublime there was no
plan at the outset to uh about to create
a balance
um this book um like at least
like uh i was at the truck but that's
not it
uh cloud atlas it has a similar
uh structure to cloud atlas in that each
section of the book
has uh chapters that come together at
the very end
but don't necessarily flow temporally
one to the other and so i felt
illustrations would help the reader
understand
that she was moving into a whole new
realm as she moved from section to
section
each illustration is taken from a scene
in one of the chapters in each part of
the book each of the seven parts
and um eric i've conceived of what they
should look like
i went through a few illustrators but
earth by far the best
and we really clicked yeah there's some
of my favorites shown here and a
reminder you can find james on his
website which i have linked underneath
his
his visage we can also find him on
twitter at jamesvictorjord
j or d uh not uh the full name because
twitter won't allow it
uh and the the main thing you know i'm
an astrophysicist so i want to talk
about some of the astrophysical
application you know aspects of the book
uh i think it is quite uh quite
fascinating that you blend
them together for me it's so daunting to
think about writing
a fiction book it's almost more daunting
than a non-fiction book because a
nonfiction book
you can rely on facts and and your
historical recollection as i did in
losing the nobel prize
uh i actually lived these events but
these nobody's lived these events i mean
at least i hope not some of them are
pretty graphic
as you know um and uh and and i just
wonder you know kind of
advice to people like me who would like
to eventually write a work of fiction
have some nascent ideas but
nowhere near the level of concreteness
that my
non-fiction book had how do you advise
somebody like me who's not an you know
an english major
by any means as you probably can tell
how do you advise someone like me
to pursue a dream of doing you know
writing the great american novel
the second great an american novel after
this one of course after gatsby
well first just to go back there's an
overriding theme in this book
which is the question what is real and i
don't think you can
address what is real just uh by looking
at
uh the surface of the planet earth
and and i think that that's important uh
how would i advise you
well you're a terrific writer i have
uh read losing the nobel prize twice
and i've listened to it once uh and so i
wouldn't worry about the writing
everybody has a different style
when it comes to fiction some people
want to outline
some people like t.c boyle outline would
be anethema
john john irving would say if you can't
if you don't know what the last
chapter's about you're lost and tc boyle
would say the opposite
um so with flannery o'connor um
you have a great if you have a story in
mind
then uh you begin with that
and you have to write every day
you have to set aside some time and um
like i said in your case i wouldn't
worry about the pros it's just
um uh very evocative your writing is
beautiful and evocative so i would
encourage you to write something that's
science fiction
from the little science fiction i have
read um
some of it is disappointing some of the
big winning
uh books are disappointing um
ursula le guins i'm trying to think in
the name of it'll come to me in a minute
um uh she her science is terrible
she writes science fiction and she makes
up things and they happen in outer space
but they could just
as well or in other planets but she
hasn't really described correctly what's
going on
uh she botches einstein's theories um
then you you have um
well my mind is is losing it at the
moment
uh who wrote marty andy weir
yeah he's he's a terrific writer and
every
the one of the uh virtues of his book
is that everything in it could possibly
happen
but it's not a really a terribly
interesting story
i mean he gets he gets left there and
then they go back and get him and they
bring him back to earth
ursula le guin writes very interesting
stories with complex
human and political problems uh in them
uh this book that just won the uh hugo
award the three body problem
the science and that is just
they don't conform to anything that we
understand about the laws of physics
you know people deflate themselves and
all the water goes out of them
and then they re-inflate themselves it's
an interesting idea a planet
trying to revolve around three suns that
are orbiting each other
did you lose me again i see it yep
uh but the science is is you know you
kind of if you care about the science
uh being somewhat true to life
then um it'll lose you
yeah yeah we're hoping to have andy weir
on the podcast
uh in a few months he's uh he's a he is
not an alum of ucsd he went to ucsd
like kim stanley robinson like david
brin like the benford brothers
vast numbers of amazing science fiction
writers call
ucsd their alma mater but not him he
didn't graduate so
maybe that's why the the gaps there are
that you found but he has another book
coming out called
uh uh project hail mary and i'm
scheduled to hopefully talk to him in
may
uh i'll let you know when that comes out
uh reminder we're talking to
james victor jordan today please follow
him on twitter
please go to his website his website is
really magnificent
i don't know who does the website jim
but it's such a fun website to play
around with i i get lost in it when i
when i do it as i do with your writing
uh please follow him you'll find some
video trailers for the book
which are uh filled with the
illustrations
which are incredible works of art not
just it's not just a work of literature
it's a work of art as well
and you'll find the these blurbs these
in comia from kip thorne from tc
boyle uh from from you know some of the
most renowned authors in history and
you can also check out and leave a
review of it on amazon goodreads and
elsewhere
and you'll find that it has you know
just almost uncountable uh numbers
constellations of five star reviews so
congratulations on this
i want to know do you get you mentioned
a little bit of your of your
prescription for working on a book
daily habits writing every day i wonder
you know
if if you found the process addictive or
if you want to branch out i know you
have tentative plans i don't know if you
want to talk about it for a follow-up
involving perhaps some of the characters
again i don't like to get into too much
detail because
it's much easier to give away you know
kind of the the spoil the book for
for people and i want them to have it
the savoring experience of it
uh but can you talk about future plans
and whether or not you find the process
addictive
when i'm in it um it's addictive i have
to do it
all the time because i have add if i'm
into something 100
and if i get out of it i spend some days
doing other things and then it's sort of
like going to the gym or something like
that
i can easily be distracted and have to
get back into it so
uh i think every successful writer that
you will talk to
uh either in terms of their being a
bestseller
or they're uh being having a lot of
literary awards will tell you it's
just something you have to do every day
um
i would imagine losing the nobel prize
you thought about it every day but you
probably wrote a little bit
i'm guessing yeah i tried to yeah it was
hard because we were dealing i mean hard
in a good way we had
little kids running around and uh
there's still some little kids running
around
uh which is uh which is always fun but
yeah
carving out the time making it a part of
your profession even though it isn't my
profession
uh necessarily my my job is to build uh
astronomical telescopes and take them to
the world's extremes
but uh but for me the kind of writing
and even the podcast has become
a chance as i think i said to you months
ago you know we had to delay it a couple
times because of covid and my schedule
and uh i said you know what i like about
the podcast
is that in contra distinction to my day
job where i might have to talk to
somebody as i do in
16 minutes from now i have to talk to
some contractor about building
a a roadway at 17 000 feet in the
atacama desert of chile
that's someone i have to talk to but
when i get to chat with you it's someone
i want to talk to
and the other people that i've gotten to
uh to know
and you start to change your identity
when you become a writer when you
produce something and so i encourage
everybody necessarily to write a book i
don't think everyone should publish a
book i
i think you should only write a book
when it can't not
be written in a sense and i feel like
the themes in this book i want to
explore
next because they're not um it's very
difficult to define it and in fact i was
worried at first can i understand this
book
uh not not because of intel but because
it's such a broad sweeping
scope of the book ranging from as they
say murder mystery to
violent crime to the criminal justice
system to like
native americans to just incredible
uh breath and then throwing astrophysics
on top of it but because it has this
core of
you know a crime true crime story or
whatever a fictional crime story
um i want to talk about that uh as you
know i've talked a lot about
uh free will determinism reality
consciousness on this podcast i want to
ask you
where do you where do you think that
this comes into play in the criminal
justice system
are you believer in determinism are you
believer in free will
where do you fall on that spectrum well
i'm a believer
in free will i know stephen hawking said
free will is an illusion
um if you're not a i'm a lawyer if
you're not
a believer in free will then how do you
ethically punish a criminal
because the crime was they had no choice
it was
going to be and probably there's
most people believe some there's some
mixture in between
you don't really have existentialists
will say everybody has freedom
even if you're in a prison cell or in a
concentration camp or personal four camp
you've got the freedom of your thoughts
and
i think that is not true harsh
if you don't if you have hunger if you
have pain
you don't have the type of freedom that
we usually
uh believe so they're anatomically maybe
we're determined we'll be hungry if we
don't eat
uh consciously we can think of anything
we want
uh we have free will although again if
you're hungry you're not going to be
thinking about much more than
getting that next meal uh killing the
beast bringing it home for the family to
to feed them it's it's a mixture
i do i do address free will and
determinism extensively in the book
right and so you know i wonder as i'm
reading it
you know because you portray it in a
balanced way how
you you know what what you really
believe and so it's good to it's good to
have that the characters you know and
the explication of it are different of
course but
um i've had in fact with your friend who
you introduced me to leonard milad now
who was stephen hawking's you know
perhaps most prolific collaborator
and in fact wrote you know some of the
the final books that steven never wrote
including uh the grand design uh
he had said you
he wrote the first ones too uh a brief
history of time
uh but he he didn't get co-author credit
but he was in
everyone i didn't know i didn't know
that leonard wrote the first a brief
history of time
i thought i thought he wrote the second
one the briefer history of time i'll
have to ask him about that
yeah he didn't write it he co-wrote it
and apparently all the way to the end as
i gave the anecdote earlier stephen had
the final say
yeah and you know stephen of course
didn't necessarily believe in it but as
roger penrose has been a four-time guest
on my show
has said uh about stephen it didn't
matter what you thought
you always could find stephen agreeing
with you because he changed his mind so
often
and the former uh uh you met you quote
and you got extensive help from the
uh the the previous richard feynman
professor of physics at caltech namely
kip thorne i spoke recently to the
current holder
of that chair who's uh who is now than
john preskill who's an amazing intellect
and we talked a lot about the bets that
he had with stephen i remember when they
made these bets
and then you know stephen would
capitulate and so but um but leonard and
i had a
very interesting and and really quite um
uh
maybe agitated it might not be the right
word but we had a very intense
conversation with frank wilczyk which
you can find and deepak chopra
so it's deepak chopra me frank wilcheck
and leonard milad now in conversation
and uh and some of they were going at it
uh frank
and leonard i found it very interesting
because leonard is a as a
essentially as i deter as i can
understand it a
a proponent of you know super
determinism
that everything is determined in the way
function of the big bang and if we we
just can't understand it but if we could
and then on the other side deepak is
saying well there's quantum you know
uh magic that you know and so we were
all kind of like just criticizing deepak
who's a good friend by the way
uh but you know don't get too woo-woo on
us but this notion of of like
you know determinism being determined
you know everything uh the one thing i
will get from leonard and that comes
through in yearbook as well
is that yeah there is how can you blame
somebody how can you have a justice
system and it was actually
wilcheck the nobel laureate the quantum
chromodynamics
explicator he was saying that no because
then how could you punish people if
everything is determined
and it was leonard milano your friend of
mine
saying no it's everything's determined i
find it um
kind of surprising i would have thought
the other way around but
in terms of determinism nowadays we hear
all sorts of things related to
consciousness
and there's touched upon the book as
well um how you know
awareness and and blame and so forth
there's this whole notion now of
of you know kind of super consciousness
or pan psychism
what do you make of that that that you
know everything is conscious and
everything has at its root layer of
reality a perception that's unique
to the object itself where do you fall
on that spectrum
personally that's not my perspective at
all
in the book there are characters who
believe that everything
is is alive stones trees
and that the deepak's uh
uh belief also and i know that from
having read the war of the world views
henry james said the author should not
uh have a point of view that comes
across
in the book but the characters should
even if
the uh even if the author is the even if
there's a first person narrator
and so i tried to do that in this book
so
do i believe uh in shamanism
uh that there's a non-ordinary reality
where
shamans can travel with
their power animals well personally i
think i'm too much of an empiricist
but so there is evidence
there is inferential evidence that they
do this
because over centuries shamans practiced
uh virtually the same type of
medicine and
they were separated by continents and
geographical
distances that were so far they could
not have possibly
have communicated and someone into this
state using drugs like in peru
and some used did it doing chants and
rattles
uh they got into this state um
the characters in my book don't use
drugs to go into a state of uh
of uh non-ordinary reality but how do
you explain the fact
that they were doing similar things and
having similar beliefs and describing
similar things
over the centuries so it's an inference
um
but i guess i'm too much of an
empiricist but my but in in the book
i i have characters who believe that and
they and they endeavor to express it
yeah and i'm always wondering you know
is this the author as you say because
a good author won't reveal if it's his
or her perspective
uh along those lines you know i felt you
got into very fraught
territory that could have been very
risky you're a
presumably caucasian male who's uh
in a in a heterosexual relationship uh
that you thank your wife you acknowledge
your wife's
loving you know tenderness and help uh
and and
you're a lawyer who's lived for a long
time as i gather in santa monica
california and here you are writing you
know book that takes place in
large part from the perspective of uh of
a you know mixed race
native american maybe uh you know and
and and
kind of consult in consultation with the
criminal justice system he encounters
africa
how did you you know and there's you
know scenes written from female
perspectives obviously
like what gave you the you know the
hutzpah the
the courage to do that uh and and uh
and especially in a first work because i
i would be kind of scared to broach some
of those those
aspects of this novel there are writers
who um claim that if you're not native
american you have no right
to write from the american point of view
louise erdog maybe
um uh tc boyle however
uh writes uh his book
um uh world's end
has a name reckon who's a main character
uh
if you're a writer you should be able to
write from a woman's point of view and
tc both number of books from women's
perspectives you're an artist yeah and
an artist
you should be able to inhabit different
thought patterns different feelings
different bodies even
and so i had i had people criticize
me and say well you'll you know you'll
never get a following nobody'll ever
read this book because you're not
uh half black and a half shaman and
half money right i grew up florida
the people i wanted i ne needed i felt
an oppressed people
or people to whom the criminal justice
system had been unfair
uh and that's my characters just grew
that way
yeah and the metaphor the everglades and
kind of the primeval
uh and the canoes as time transporters
and places that go through time and
space
i found it very uh very gripping and i'm
not alone
uh and and i do want to you know maybe
close this section before we get to
as you know i'm very uh pressed for time
i i always thought
james that astronomers would spend our
times on
telescopes but actually we're much more
often on telecons than telescopes
unfortunately
uh so i do have a couple of questions
that we'll get to that i ask all my
listeners all my guests who honor me by
coming on the show
uh but before we get there i i really do
want to you know kind of close with
one big picture question that kind of
grew out of it uh
and and a conversation i had with
lawrence tribe who's an attorney
constitutional law professor at harvard
was barack obama's uh law professor and
you know as you know i've been thinking
a lot about
artificial intelligence and how we can
have applications and implications for
physics
i'm in the process now turning galileo's
written words into audio form
with carlo rovelli and others um
including jim gates and many other
eminent physicists frank wilcek has
agreed to play a part in it
and uh my next step after that is to
take the words and the audio and put it
into an ai
that i'm calling galil aio and
and kind of converse with him and i said
i started to think about this with
regard to lawrence tribe and the
constitution
and you as an attorney i want to ask are
there implications for artificial
intelligence
in the criminal justice system which is
featured very prominently
in the speed of life could we get to an
artificial
you know uh supreme court could we get
into a situation where
we have advanced capabilities from a
general artificial intelligence
that allow us to make perfect perfect
decisions in terms of criminal justice
in terms of decisions of uh
consciousness is something right or
wrong
i hope not even given the current
constitution of the philosophies on the
court
certainly a lot of things get done
automatedly with artificial intelligence
if you will
yours can be screened and ruled out on
on per on a perfectly objective basis
uh so it could be streamlined a lot of
the court system is going electronic now
but in terms of um
uh i hope not and maybe that's just my
fear
maybe i'm wrong about that
so uh so i'm gonna take some questions
from the audience
i do see eric is in the audience eric
savage who's the illustrator i
i do love the shoe illustration that was
one of my favorite ones eric is
is commenting on here um so other people
are talking about
uh the ability to make split-second
judgments
may not be good in criminal justice in
other words the jury process which again
features prominently
here um you know is a deliberative one
and it can take you know weeks or months
even
to reach consensus so if we had an you
know instantaneous general artificial
intelligence
maybe we'd lose some of that in the
criminal justice system
so i want to take any questions um
from the audience but be while i'm
teeing up so folks you can
type your questions in the chat box i am
monitoring that
as we are as we are chatting live and as
i say
james i always ask my guests the
following questions
uh some of which will touch upon some of
the characters we've already mentioned
the first question i ask relates to the
nobel prize as you know
the nobel prize comprised a material
will
as an attorney you'll appreciate that i
pursued this as a
as an executor or somebody you know
suing an estate or something like that
because i don't feel the nobel prize has
lived up to its uh to its legal
obligations let alone its its moral
obligations but part of the nobel prize
was to
say that one more time it hasn't lived
up to what alfred nobel intended in
physics
that's right yes and and it's and so uh
but but the
the aspect that's uh jermaine to my
question right now
is uh whether or not uh you did what
alfred did
which is to construct an ethical will so
not a monetary will not a trust in a
state's
plan but an ethical will which in hebrew
we call a zava ah
which is basically a wisdom will and i
want to ask you as alfred said
he wanted to endow the prizes that most
benefited
humankind that was his ethical component
the material component was the money he
left
and the practical component which is
mostly ignored is you know how many
people could win it
how often they have to be nominated etc
but i want to ask you james uh
when uh you reach the biblical age of
120 years old
how uh you know how do you want to leave
the world in terms of wisdom or what do
you want to leave the world in terms of
the wisdom that you've accrued
throughout your your time on earth well
for this book i would say that is
not to make snaps so
uh something happened i just got cut out
but hopefully it'll come back up
um switching channels let's see if this
comes back up so yes we got that
and i think this is still alive let's
see here
it may not be but hopefully this is good
here
sorry about that we might have a rare
two-part episode
which uh which has never happened before
and uh you could probably guess why
because it's it is a challenge to get
all the technology to work here let's
see hopefully this is working and
recording i see it's still showing live
so that is a positive sign you still see
me and you still see it live
no i don't see you but i see me okay
yeah i wanted to have you focus on you
uh so that we could uh so that you could
answer the questions directly to the
camera let's see here
uh i am now going to check 32 it still
says it's live
anyway uh so let's keep going the next
question i have is
relates to what i call the monolith and
you might know from arthur c clarke's
2001 a space odyssey that these aliens
leave these monoliths throughout the
solar system for human beings to find
and one of the things they they find are
these monoliths in the plains of africa
and they don't know what to do with it
so they start freaking out hitting with
a bone and whatnot but i want to ask you
if if you had access to a million
or billion year lasting time capsule
like these monoliths might be
what piece of knowledge would you put in
it and to inspire you i'll quote from
richard feynman
fyman said if in some cataclysm all of
scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures
what statement would convey the most
information about what we know
and he said it's everything is made of
atoms what would you put in that that
really
um demonstrates what we've learned as
human beings or
you know uh comprises the knowledge that
humanity has accrued
during our four billion years of
evolution
don't judge others by differences
especially superficial differences
between them and yourselves
edging skin color uh
that would be hard for me right
yeah that's uh that is a great base of
wisdom to convey and the last piece of
wisdom conveyed
uh today will go back in time now i'm
going to ask you
advice to your former self before i have
to break off in time
and attend to another telecom which you
can tell how much i look forward to
these telecoms
but it's the price you pay to be a
scientist these days anyway
arthur c clarke who is the namesake of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination here at uc san diego he said
the only way of discovering the limits
of what's possible is to venture a
little way past them
into the impossible that's the name of
the podcast uh someone asked you what
aspect of
life now that you've lived it at the
speed of life what aspect of life
perplexed you and mystified you as a 20
year old that now makes sense to you
because you had the courage and dignity
to go into the impossible
women
you're not the first person who said
that uh this week in fact i had another
person say that exact same thing
i was on his podcast and i asked him
that and he said you know he said i
would go back in time and
and tell me to ask out more women and i
said if i did that i'd just get more
rejections than i already had
but uh yes
all right well i have to thank you so
much james this is
uh this has been a treat i'm sorry it
took so long i'm sorry we had such
technical difficulties
but um but it's really a treat and and i
and i do appreciate
the uh the hand inscription i bought the
book on amazon
just so i could leave a verified review
uh of this wonderful book
uh which means so much to me that you
came on the show we didn't get to talk
about everything
i'm excited to hear about a future
upcoming book do you want to say
anything about that oh i'm very honored
to have been on your show
i'm looking forward to your next book
because losing the nobel prize was
really uh it just grabbed me and and i
loved the way
you were part of it you're intertwined
personally throughout it in the
scientific mystery
so i hope you're going to be writing
another book i'm writing a book right
now about
twins a brother and a sister who
are close but have a falling out over
the disposition of their father's estate
wow don't
say that again i said as you can tell
i'm staying away from the law
yeah that's right well it might not be
such a bad idea you know
edwin hubble said his father wanted him
to be a lawyer and he actually went to
oxford
and he uh he studied laws or whatever
they call it over there
and then he quit and he came back and uh
and he told his father
i'd rather be a second-rate astronomer
than a first-rate lawyer
and so maybe you're doing the same thing
maybe you're being a first-rate writer
and a first-rate lawyer or maybe some
other combination thereof but james
victor jordan james jordan.com please
everybody go out get this book
it's a phenomenal work of literature and
art thanks to eric hi eric
i hope you're still watching uh i really
appreciate uh your contributions
to both the book obviously and the
podcast are you going to work with eric
on the
sort of semi-sequel follow-up to speed
of light
i will work with eric uh as long as
he'll have me
to work with i actually have a pain from
the new book that i've
for almost for over a year i've been
meaning to
send to eric and ask him what he thinks
about an illustration for it
but um yeah i mean eric is
multi-talented
uh it's not only in drawing
illustrations but it's
he's my he designed and maintains my web
uh
he can do videos movies he's just he's
awesome
he really can find links to him on my
website
i was just gonna say that eric savage is
the man we're talking about
a legend in this world james thank you
so much for going into the impossible
have a wonderful weekend
and yes i'm going to take you up on that
i'm going to need some advice for my
novel
uh you know losing the the pulitzer
prize
i think that's my next one all right i
will uh that's funny i'll send you some
great thank you so much jays have a
wonderful day thank you guys